[Applaudissements]
allez-y non je vous donne ma mère
katherine moi parce que c'est vraiment
ch et profond mais la belle aya là pour
l'instant t si j'ai envie de me faire
des mails à des matériaux non parce que
ça fait mal je pense et agit avec la vie
d'écriture sûrement une grosse peluche
qui ne trouvait bien de surprises calme
toi tu m'as donné un coup de poing
marine est pas c'est quoi marie lapierre
n'a même pas ce que c'est ça moi c'est
quoi est ce que voulait bien joué on
peut aimer la vie mais je veux dire je
veux jouer au vrai jeu qu'à l'origine
alors je vais pas là dedans à quoi
qu'est-ce qu'a pascual à votre avis
c'est quand il veut dire juste à
l'endroit même décision si tu fromage
[Applaudissements]
les rémissions jeudi précise et adaptée
du livre un euro non non non non vous
savez les prix mais bon je vais me
renseigner les années 70
franchement les gens étaient vraiment
sympas avec toi c'est plus facile et peu
fatigué là il ya aucun problème le plus
facile si tu as été au cinéma récemment
ta tête une idée mais allez-y vélizy
aller à l'inra s'il vous plaît tu venir
faire les vraies émissions en euros et
messieurs vous aviez du rythme va durer
six heures et que c'est sa dictature
je le sens pas parce qu'il a dit cinéma
ça veut dire que c'est une araignée j'ai
pas du tout il n'y a pas d'art hennessy
non non non non je peux pas s'y remet et
ben et non avant dit je peux pas je
dansais groupe les patrons je peux pas
renier je peux pas je vous fais moi la
passe et qui s'est marié s'est pas
vraiment énorme teddy cinéma spiderman
zorro mais a tout de suite
si les mecs et spider man ben c'est pas
trop tôt c'était tranquille dans captain
america un bouclier et bézy détente
ça va rien de parler franchement dû
croire [ __ ] mais j'ai de presse sur la
vigne jamais rechapage express aux
punaises